if there was a Greek exit there will be
massive contagion spreads in the
periphery would widen rather than narrow
being a down the way they are right now
because the DC reactions that we run on
other eurozone banks and once one
countries out people and ask who's going
to be next that's why I think
economically and financially it doesn't
make sense to have Greek exit even the
German realize it and also geopolitical
consequences the Russians are becoming
more aggressive not just in Ukraine and
the Baltics but also in the Balkans from
Moldova to bulgaria to serbia to grease
it is an orthosis country if Greece were
to exit the eurozone with may end up in
the arms of the Russian bear and now
you've also had the job real problems in
Europe you had terrorists accidents from
Paris to Denmark the fgs you can come
back to blow themselves up throughout
Europe and the Middle East is a mess so
if you think about it even from a German
point of view doesn't make sense to have
an exit of grease from the eurozone
agrees that represents only two percent
of the eurozone GDP and cause economic
financial and political damage to the
eurozone therefore while they've been
market concerns about Greece I think
there will be a compromise between the
two sides on the deficit on the debt on
the structural reform I don't think that
Greek accident from the eurozone is
likely